is the iPhone 14 plus camera really that
much worse than the 14 pro Max well I
shot a ton of different photos and
videos to see how much of a difference
is there really and should you spend the
extra money starting off with colors and
contrast I consistently saw that the 14
plus was a little bit more saturated and
had a little bit more contrast added
whereas the 14 pro Max it's a little bit
more true to life a little bit more
natural looking like in this shot right
here with that it also seemed to have a
little bit better dynamic range if you
look at that tree on the right hand side
where the 14 plus is slightly blown out
and now let's get into what everybody
cares about detail especially with that
48 megapixel lens and in this normal
wide shot you cannot tell a difference
and even if we crop in the difference is
minuscule and that's because this is a
regular photo not the pro raw switching
over to Pro Rod to get all that detail
you might actually think that the 14
plus looks more detailed that is just
because it has a lot more sharpening
applied and I'll be honest the 14 plus
does a great job but when we punch in
look at that the 14 pro Max looks so
much more natural with a ton of actual
detail from the image that was captured
compared to the 14 plus that has some
artifacting over sharpening worst
dynamic range it basically looks like
you're comparing a cell phone to a DSLR
going back to Skyline now looks more
detailed and more natural and then
punching in we have a lot of fine detail
compared to over sharpening now what
about that 3x lens the 14 plus doesn't
have a telephoto so as a digitally crop
but I was surprised by how good it still
looked the new photonic engine is doing
a great job but we do see a dynamic
range difference if you look at the
shrub at the top it is blown out on the
14 plus whereas the 14 pro Max you have
more detail and it looks more natural
now we also have the extra benefit of
being able to crop in more so the 14
plus can only do a five times crop
compared to 15 but if I crop the image
after the fact I mean look at that
difference there if both phones are set
to 5x there is a difference but it's not
huge and then our 14 pro Max and go up
to 15 which is awesome and if we
digitally crop the image afterwards I
mean it is insane what we see at the top
right we have that STCU sign which is
not even visible on the other shot and
if we take a look at a building like
this I mean one looks like a usable
image the other does not I love being
able to isolate a subject without
getting other stuff in the shot and then
if you're zooming in the same I mean it
is crazy now Apple made a big deal about
the ultra wide but in my shots the
difference is so small a little bit more
contrasty on the 14 plus like before but
if we look at a fine detail it is hard
to see the difference in this tougher
mixed lighting shot they look so similar
and even cropping in I wouldn't say that
the ultrite is any better on the 14 pro
Max at least in the day a will cover the
night time in just a bit and switching
over to the selfie camera this camera
actually is identical on both phones so
it looks very similar and then even here
we have a little bit more contrast in
the 14 pro Max but looking at the fine
detail it is pretty much identical but
the one difference I noticed is that if
you're shooting a portrait shot which
needs a lot more computational power
that is where the 14 pro Max starts to
look a lot better because of its a16
processor now if you're gonna be buying
any of the new iPhone 14 models you're
definitely gonna have to get a reliable
case like one of the new iPhone 14
impact cases from our sponsor case defy
which are engineered with the new
twister design known as ecoshock which
provides 20 increased protection
compared to the previous generation up
to five times the military standard
which means it's been drop tested over
130 times to ensure ecoshock doesn't
wear off and they're sustainably made
with 65 recycled and plant-based on
materials they're all very high quality
and they're now available with more
prints than ever before and you can get
them with magsafe compatibility for all
of your accessories like wireless
chargers and wallets and of course we
put the new Ultra impact case with the
ecoshock protection designed to the test
by drop testing our iPhone 14 with it
coming out basically good as new since
it has drop protection up to 11 and a
half feet high so check out one of K
Supply's new iPhone 14 cases using the
link down below and save 15 off your
order today now getting into portrait
shots which I love you guys can see that
the 14 pro Max has a wider lens but
otherwise they look very similar now one
benefit I love is the new 2x mode for
portraits so here it looks more natural
on the 14 pro Max which on the 14 plus I
had to walk closer so you see more of
the background and Elon slightly
distorted and then switching over to the
three times telephoto lens his face is
so distorted on the 14 plus because it's
still that same wide length lens
compared to the 14 pro Max looks great
with that you can't always get closer
and you can't zoom in on the 14 plus
before taking a picture so here I could
actually take a portrait shot and I also
found that even though the 14 pro Max's
camera is wider you can be further back
and still get a portrait whereas the 14
plus cannot and even here where I'm
really far away the 14 pro Max let me
take a portrait shot where we couldn't
with the other one and that is awesome
now not only is that 2x portion mode
convenient but it actually makes the
lighting better as well because it's
looking at just that part now some
people still say you know what take the
photo crop in so here we don't have that
convenience and then once I crop the
whole image on the 14 plus just looks a
little bit fake a little bit too over
sharpened not as natural as having that
extra lens so if you're somebody likes
to take portraits you definitely want
the 14 pro Max and with that it can also
take macro shots like this one right
here with the 14 plus you're gonna have
to take an image like this and then crop
it in and it's okay but look at all that
noise and artifacting doing the same
thing with the 14 pro Max looks better
but of course you could just use that
macro mode to get all that fine detail
without the noise now as far as
panoramas the 14 plus actually looks
better the colors look better it's a
little bit more detailed and that's just
because there's so much extra data that
Apple has to use for the 14 pro Max with
its 48 megapixel sensor so it looks
worse comparing the dynamic range the 14
pro Max is slightly better just like I
showed you guys before and if we expose
for the sky both are fairly dark now we
can bring up the mids and some of those
Shadows but they don't look great but
the cool thing is with Pro raw you can
bring all of that up and it looks much
better much more natural and more
detailed and now let's take a look at
night mode here I have an ultra wide
shot when the sun has just set and the
14 per Max looks a little bit cleaner
stepping inside with the main camera so
14 pro Max looks just slightly better
with slightly less noise and testing out
3x crop here I would say that the 14
plus actually looks better this was both
night mode is a lot dark in real life
but the crop from the main sensor looks
better than that dedicated 3x lens
surprisingly the same thing happens here
the 14 plus is crop is a little bit
brighter and has less noise than the 14
pro Max but once it gets even darker the
14 pro Max will actually do the digital
crop as well and this is why this image
looks more detailed with less noise now
the killer feature of the 14 pro series
is the lidar sensor which allows you to
take night mode portraits when the 14
plus you can't and depending on how dark
it is the difference can be massive like
this shot right here and then even
darker here where you almost can't see
Emily with the 14 plus I also took a
flash shot which I don't like doing but
it does look nicer on the 14 pro Max
because of its sensor and then switching
to the ultra wide in a really dark
situation we also see a big difference
this difference is noticeable in a lot
of different situations where the 14 per
Max is just way better and switching to
the main sensor here the difference
isn't huge but we see a little bit more
detail and a little bit more stars with
the 14 pro Max I have to say apple did a
great job with the added processing in
the same sensor from the 13 Pro lineup
where it looks really close here on a
tripod for 30 seconds not much different
as far as nighttime selfies I would
actually say I like the 14 pluses better
it has a little bit less color in my
face and then when it's crazy dark they
are very similar take a look at video I
thought the 14 plus would look better
because there's less data that has to
over sample but they are very similar
probably slightly sharper on the 14 pro
Max dynamic range is also very close but
overall I'm surprised by how close it is
shooting with the main camera the detail
looks almost the same and then if we
zoom in to three times which is the
maximum that the 14 can do it looks just
slightly worse than the 14 pro Max both
these can shoot cinematic mode and while
they look very similar the 14 pro Max is
more accurate and as far as nighttime
video when you still have some light
shining they look very similar but when
it gets darker the 14 plus does have a
little bit more noise especially if you
look at the bushes right there it's
moving all around and the image I think
is slightly darker overall and for the
ultra wide camera I mean you can barely
see anything on the 14 plus with a 14
pro Max has less noise and a brighter
shot and even though they both have the
same selfie cameras because of the a16
you have a Brighter Image and a lot less
noise in the face as well so should you
buy a 14 plus or a 14 pro max if you
care about photos and video well on the
video side I think it's very close but
on the photo side if you love taking
portrait shots and taking Zoom shots and
regular lighting the difference is
pretty substantial and of course we have
that macro mode that allows you to get
really close to your subjects and then
have an ability to take those large Pro
route files that look more natural I
mean I think overall if you care about
photos you should spend the extra money
along with all the other extra features
that you get so if you guys want to see
our full comparison you guys can click
right over there and check out that
video or click above to subscribe this
has been Max with Max Tech and I'll see
you in the next video
[Music]